امس طلع اعلان عمل كثير من الجدل فمجموعه
علماء طلعوا واعلنوا تحديث الساعه القيامه
وقالوا انه العالم اقرب للنهايه من اي وقت
مضى وان البشريه بتبعد ثواني عن منتصف
الليل اللي هو خلاص النهايه والعلماء اللي
بنتكلم عنهم يعني مو اي علماء اي كلام نحن
بنتكلم عن مجلس العلوم والامن ومجلس
الرعاه في نشره علماء الذره يعني جماعه من
بينهم 11 شخص فائزين بجائزه نوبل
بتاعي تمام
[موسيقى]
السكن
الا انه غيروا ساعه القيامه لتقترب من
منتصف الليل وانه المسافه صارت ثواني
متقائق انه الحرب الاوكرانيه لها علاقه في
الموضوع واضح انه في كثير ناس
لانه من وقت الاعلان والموضوع متصدر
عمليات البحث عن الموضوع على جوجل زادت
حول العالم والناس بتسال ايش ساعه القيامه
هذه وايش تحديثها الجديده هذا واللي
بيقولوا قربنا من النهايه يعني هو العلم
عارف النهايه متى واحنا قربنا خلاص وايش
علاقه الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه يعني كلها
اسئله صراحه طلبنا اجاباتها من صديقنا
الدكتور محمد قاسم
اقتربت الساعه الى منتصف الليل ودق ناقوس
الخطر هذه هي الصوره اللي نستلهمها من
ساعه القيامه العلماء حركه ذراعها عشر
ثواني الى الامام ليصبح ما تبقى من الوقت
دقيقه ونصف نحن نقترب من حرف الكارثيه
وعواقب القنابل الذريه تغير المناخ
والاسلحه البيولوجيه الكارثيه هذه الان هي
اقرب مرحله وضعت فيها الساعه الى منتصف
الليل على مر 76 عام من ان تاسست سعد اللي
اسس لها العلماء اللي عملوا على مشروع من
حاتم والقنبله الذريه بعد ان راوا مقدار
الدمار اللي تلحقه على البشريه هدف الساعه
الاساسي اللي من اجلها انشاها العلماء هو
الانذار من القنابل الذريه خصوصا بعد
نكزكي وهيروشيما
نحن نعلم انها تقضي على مدن كامله من كتله
صغيره جدا من الطاقه الذريه اليوم الساعه
تجمع بين مجموعه من المخاطر بالاضافه
للقنابل الذريه مثل تغير المناخ المخاطر
البيولوجيه وحتى التكنولوجيا المزعزعه مثل
نشر المعلومات المظلله سبرانيا او استخدام
التكنولوجيا التجسسيه او حتى استخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي لالحاق الضرر يعتقد
البعض ان الساعه تتنبا بمستقبل البشريه
لكن هذا الشيء بعيد عن الحقيقه الساعه
تعتمد على اعضاء مجلس اداره منهم عشره
حاصلين على جائزه نوبل للبحث في البيانات
والاحصائيات الخاصه بالقنابل الذريه
ويبحثون ايضا في كميات ثاني اكسيد الكربون
في الاجواء ودرجه حموضه البحار وارتفاع
منسوب المياه وكذلك ينظر الاعضاء في مجهود
ياسين والناشطين في التقليل من المخاطر
الذريه والبيئيه وغيرها
وبناء عليه يختارون حاله الساعه هدف
الساعه ليستنبه انما ذكر حاله نحن فيها
الان ودعوه عامه الناس والمختصين حتى
يتناقشون في هذا الموضوع حتى نحمي مستقبل
الناس والارض
[موسيقى]